Next, let's go over the types of blueprints you may expect to see inside of Unreal.
So there are several types of blueprints.
You've got the level blueprint, which we referred to before.
We've got blueprint classes, which are almost like a modular way to start building out your
code.
If you put it into a blueprint class, it means you can use it in many different areas, whereas
a level blueprint is very specific to that one level that you're working on.
You have data only blueprints.
Say you want to store some data, but you don't necessarily need the interactivity behind
it.
You can get that data only blueprint.
You have blueprint interfaces, which we briefly touched on a couple of minutes ago, but a
blueprint interface essentially allows you to communicate from one blueprint to another.
You've got blueprint macros, which is almost like a wrapper for some scripting that you
might have inside of a blueprint.
So a macro can be repurposed in multiple blueprints if you wanted to.
The way to think about macros over functions, because functions and macros can be similar.
You might see those terms quite frequently.
Macros can actually house latent functionality.
So what I mean by that is if you wanted to create this bit of code that you want to reuse
in multiple places, it may have some kind of delay.
You may have an event fire, say an explosion goes off and you want to wait five seconds
and trigger a vehicle moving across the scene.
That can be stored in a macro because it has latent functionality.
It has a delay in there, whereas a function would not be able to house a delay.
A function has to fire through and process the code, but it can't wait for any kind
of dependency on the functionality.
So hopefully that does give you a bit of context over what macros might be.
And then you've got animation blueprints, which again, very visual driven and it's
almost like a state machine setup.
And you can even communicate with animation blueprints into your level blueprint or another
blueprint class.
Say you want to trigger some certain code on maybe a character that's moving around
the scene.
You can do that through animation blueprints as well.
So level blueprints and blueprint classes are what you're going to be using most commonly.
So they're the top two examples.
So again, level blueprint is very context specific to that level.
So if you've got very specific functionality that's going on in that level, you can house
that in the level blueprint.
The way I like to think about it though, is if you're maybe making, again, going back
to this vehicle moving across the scene or a door opening and closing, if you're going
to reuse that door opening and closing across many different levels, you probably want to
make a blueprint class for it because otherwise you'd have to keep remaking it every time
on the level blueprint.
Whereas a blueprint class, you make it once and then you can use it multiple times.
So a level blueprint provides a control mechanism for level streaming, binding events to actors
placed in the level.
So again, we're doing some scripting that's very context specific to this level.
So it's a specialized type of blueprint that acts as level wide global event graph.
Each level in your project has its own level blueprint created and is there by default
and it's automatically saved when the level saves.
So when you go to file save all, the level blueprint will remember all the data.
And again, just as a reminder, you can click on the blueprint window here in your editor
and go to open level blueprint.
Blueprint classes on the other hand, often just referred to as blueprints.
When you hear people talking about using Unreal and blueprints, this is what they're referring
to.
So a blueprint class is an asset that allows content creators to easily add functionality
on top of existing gameplay classes.
So blueprints are essentially a defined new type of class or actor that can then be placed
into different maps.
So there's a door here, for example, that door can be its own blueprint actor.
So you could duplicate that door and use it in many different places.
You could even use it in different levels and that functionality would preserve and
it would be housed inside of that actor rather than on the level blueprint.
So a blueprint class is created and stored in the content browser and a blueprint actor
is an instance of a blueprint class placed in the level.
So you create all the functionality, you create the code inside of that blueprint and that
houses inside of your content browser, which is your library of assets.
And then when you drag and drop it into the scene, that has created an instance.
So if you edit that door inside of the scene, it won't actually edit the main version of
the content browser.
If you want to make any global changes to that blueprint, you'd edit the content browser
version and not the version that's placed in the level.
So when we're thinking about common classes in blueprints, you want to be thinking about
what is childhood and what type of framework you're trying to create with your blueprints.
So if we take a basic framework here, which shows the hierarchy of common classes, the
arrows indicate that the classes on the right is inheriting from the class on the left.
So it's each one from objects.
So if we take object on the left hand side, each one of them has been childhood from the
object class.
So object is at the top of the hierarchy and then you can create an actor based from an
object and then just following the bottom flow, for example, a character.
So on the bottom right is charted from the porn class, which is charted from an actor
class, which then is charted from an object class.
So the object is the end point of where the character would have been created from and
then you can get more specified functionality as you go down the chain to get the character
actor.
When you're working with blueprints, you should have a basic understanding of these scripting
terms.
When we referred to before compiling your code, that's got some kind of compiler built into
it.
So when a blueprint script has been created, it needs to be compiled.
Going back to those two buttons that I said you'd be using frequently, compile and save,
compile and save.
So compiling is a process of turning this source code, which in our example here is
the visual scripting.
So we want to turn the source code into the machine language that can be executed by the
CPU.
So compiling requires the change depending on the hardware and operating system and a
compiler is the software used to compile source code written in a programming language.
Blueprints are compiled to the bytecode level and processed by a virtual machine instead
of the hardware.
So a virtual machine is software that translates bytecode into instructions at the hardware
you can understand and process and then you can also nativeize that code, which inside
of Unreal if you ever need to nativeize blueprints, blueprints run slightly slower than C++ code.
So if you really need to get maximum performance out of your production, you can actually
convert blueprints to C++ by nativeizing these things.
Blueprint interface is a collection of one or more functions that can be added to other
blueprints and then blueprint interfaces allow different blueprints to share the data to
send from one another.
So before I was referencing this blueprint interface and talking about how you can get
an interface, you can implement an interface on two different actors.
Say you have a light switch on the wall and you have a door that you want to open, you
can actually add an interface both to the light switch and the door and then that will
create a communication channel.
Say you want to get some kind of value from the switch and pass it over to the door, you
can do that through the use of interfaces.
So a blueprint interface is an asset that's created in the content browser and you can
edit it in the Blueprint interface editor.
So I'll just show you quickly how you go about creating an interface as well.
So to create your Blueprint interface, again you probably want to organize your content
and put it inside of a Blueprint folder or sometimes I even create a Blueprint interface
folder so if I just right click BPI, so I give it a capital B, capital P and then lower
case i for Blueprint interface.
So again this is just a quick example but you just right click in the empty space, go
to Blueprints and select your Blueprint interface and that's how you get to the interface window.